I have some apologies that I have to do
no yeah I'm going to you don't have to
but because I'll tell you why
um I've been thinking about some of my
behaviors back in the day and I just
want to just apologize number one I want
to apologize for one day you and Nicole
Parker were riding in dick with Sushi's
office
right wow and he had some Tums on his
desk and I jammed in my butthole yes my
butthole started foaming
it's crazy it's crazy
my butthole started forming I shot out
couple of um pellets pellets right a
little poo came out and then dick was
mad but you laugh but in my mind I'm
like I don't think that's the right
Behavior once people are writing am I
not right
can we get a consensus in the room yeah
that's not good behavior it was funny
yeah I I was fine with it you're fine
with it I was fine with it I remember
you came in my dressing room one time
and you literally were like you're like
I'm gonna take a shirt on your floor and
I was like don't don't and you just
[__] took a [__] right in front of me
yeah yeah and it was like very
anticlimactic because I would clean it
up you just have to get your knees but
that's not normal behavior well no
wasn't it was hey it was the 2000s
George W [__] was our president
uh but it was like we were all everyone
was crazy then like any any every day we
were there there's like 10 things
happened that would have gotten people
fired oh I know yeah and then I'll the
last thing I wanted that's just the
sketches
the last day I want to apologize about
you me and Josh were doing Ben we had to
promote remember back then we had to
promote and went to Ben gleeb's talk
show or something oh this I do remember
yeah don't apologize to me it was
apologize to Mrs gleib
whatever I I mean again these these
memories like yeah comment like I'm
almost like uh like a Vietnam vet
that like like has just flashbacks of
like the name you know uh but I do
remember like we were promoting
something and Ben gleib who was a
comedian or he was a talk show he was
like a dude yeah dude yeah yeah and he
had us on and he's like we're gonna do a
fun bit I have this woman who's uh like
a fortune teller fortune teller yeah
yeah yeah and and Josh and I knew it was
a bed and we were just playing along
with a bit and Bobby was like
Bobby was like this is [__] [__]
you're a liar I don't think everything
you say is [__] I'm not I'm not down
with this like he was so mean I was so
mean to her to this woman and then we
found out it was it was Ben glebe's mom
yeah I was being such a dick but also in
the green room I was doing weird things
like I was stuffing stuff in my bottle
and just weird stuff why do you think um
why do you think you wanted to like sell
hey John what what's up you're my boy
huh for life I love it like why do you
think you always wanted to do anal on
yourself it's gay
[Laughter]
you know you throw that out there you
know they clip that you know I mean I'm
gay
I'm supportive of the LG LG you know
what I mean but of course yeah but it's
weird because you don't let any fingers
up there but why did you keep shoving
[__] up your ass when you were I think
at the time right I didn't have the
talent
I don't sell yourself
but in my mind I'm like oh these guys
can do Impressions and they're like and
they could do sir no one does a better
Connie Chung and just he's 50 United
States than you I don't know and you
know I mean they can do characters and
this is their thing right so in my mind
I'm like I'll just be weird
okay right that's part of it I think the
other part was yeah it really was the
2000s was like a very crazy decade where
first of all we were a lot of us were
loaded a lot of the time yeah like there
was a lot of
draw like people wrote drugs a lot yeah
uh but look at that look at that right
there I'm so coked up there
I cut off most of Jordan peel huh
interesting
cool guys uh but I think at that time
really it was comedy was like look at us
oh my God that's at the up front oh look
at that Jesus Christ Jesus Christ oh my
God I look like Corey Hayes oh no look
at us back then I mean we look like the
world like like a boy band and our
manager
um I'm the manager or buying my kids
I don't want to be the man he's like our
manager that will go to jail for like
sex abuse
but that 2000s don't you feel like
everyone back then was like in the 2000s
like look at my dick hole Yeah Yeah
comedy was like yeah you know what I
mean it was just so gross which I loved
I was a huge fan of it I still am I show
my dick hold a couple people this
morning
but uh I think at that time it was just
everyone was like crazy we're just like
people were just nuts yeah yeah and I I
I find myself apologizing people like
you know Flanagan I farted in her mouth
that one again you never have to
apologized to me there was never a day
where I was driving home and I was like
[__] Bobby yeah yeah but like planning
and I get that that's a good yeah that
was tough yeah he farted and I saw her
hair move oh
like literally like I saw the wind from
his yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've seen in your if you right now yeah
the Lights Went Out in the studio and
you just put a Sharpie in my hand I
could draw your [__]
um there was one sketch that you and I
did we did several of them
and I remember like we they never did
well in fact they always bomb they
bombed and I remember one time we did
one take we did in front of a live knobs
knobs yeah so is this okay you ready for
a high concept I